family of former zappos ceo tony shea is  fighting for control of his estate today  they say he did not have a will shea  passed away last week  after being injured in a house fire in  connecticut court documents show  shea's father and his brother are asking  a judge now to make them special  administrators to his estate the family  is also asking a judge  access to shea's financial and social  media accounts  and the ability to speak with his  lawyers now the shea family shared a  statement with us about his passing you  can see it here  reads in part the shea family is deeply  grateful for the outpouring of love and  respect  shown in the wake of tony's passing it  is clear to the family that he had a  profound  impact on countless people all over the  world  you can read that full statement it is  on our website 8newsnow.com